I'm Meg Wilbur and today I've been
challenged with explaining prosthetic
makeup and 11 levels of increasing
complexity
[Music]
special effects makeup is a really broad
umbrella there's old age bald caps body
painting face painting all sorts of
different things I'm defining complexity
as flourishes different textures the
small minutiae details that are often
overlooked or are not easy to replicate
level one temporary tattoo application
crafting a demon can be approached in a
lot of different ways I have decided to
create mine around the idea of someone
going and getting a tattoo that didn't
quite mean what they thought it did
travels through their bloodstream and
turns them into a demon for this step
we're going to be using something called
Pros Aid adhesive sort of like a liquid
band it's literally a medical adhesive
I'm laying down a layer of adhesive to
help the tattoo transfer stick to the
skin just a little bit better we are
going to put on a layer of prozate on
top of that and that's just to seal it
into the skin to really make sure that
it's not going to go anywhere that's
just another layer of insurance and then
after we we get that layer of prozate on
there we're going to powder it down this
is going to help marry it into the skin
it's also going to keep the Brazil from
being sticky and after we get that layer
of powder on there our final step is to
kind of wipe it off make sure that it's
all matted down and ready to go
level two multi-brush application
so for this one we're going to use a
nice red tone to really Express how
irritated and angry this tattoo is it's
starting to get infected and the way
that we're going to apply it is using
stipple brushes stipple brushes are Duo
fiber brushes you can always identify
them they have a short section of
bristles and a long section of bristles
so I like stipple brushes for this in
particular because they give a almost
pointillistic just gives you something
nice and soft that you can continue to
work with so in this level we are
introducing the use of alcohol paint and
the reason that I like alcohol paint the
most is because you can use it like a
watercolor it builds up and washes and
it looks really subtle if you think
about skin as an organ it's layered on
top of other things and alcohol paint
has the translucency to mimic actual
things that happen on your skin without
looking as opaque and kind of stagey as
a cream makeup might level three veining
we're at the part of the story where the
infection is starting to enter the
bloodstream so the brush that I'm going
to be mainly using for this is a very
very fine point brush it's a 610. in
order to get the effect of really cool
veining which is just to show the actual
veins that are capillaries of your arm
we are going to be using our stippling
technique it leaves Behind these little
points every so often and I like to use
them as the groundwork for creating
really cool veins the cool thing about
alcohol paint is that because it is
applied in washes and it is so
translucent you don't have to be
committed to anything and because we've
stippled paint on and there are voids in
areas where there's not as much paint or
there's no paint at all you can get away
with doing things like that if you over
saturate the skin with alcohol and
attempt to touch paint onto it it'll
bleed it'll it'll balloon or Blossom and
another thing to look out for is you
can't use a ton of pressure and drag it
across with multiple colors you'll start
to pick up the layers underneath it is
very easily reactivated
level 4 creating Dimension so so far all
of our techniques have been
two-dimensional techniques for this
level we're adding an additional Third
Dimension to things so we can pop out
some blisters and really add to our look
by giving it a little hype for this
level we're going to be using a two-part
silicone complex they stay totally
uncured when they're separate when you
mix them together they cure into little
silicone pieces and they can go right on
the skin and it's a platinum based
silicone and I'm gonna add a catalyst to
it to just make it cure just a little
bit faster that way we can make sure
that our little dots that we put on the
skin stay kind of raise dots after we
get those dots on the skin in the areas
that we want them we're going to add a
little bit of alcohol paint on top of
them just to give them a little extra
pop to really show that they are kind of
[ __ ] and infected I'm going to be using
a filbert brush to go in and around
these little blisters that we've created
to give them a little more dimension and
I'm going to use a flat ended brush to
add the yellow color to the blisters I
am using yellow because yellow pus and
I'm going to be using a little more of
that angry red color around the base of
those pustules so that I can really pop
them out and make sure that they read
well the next level I'll be increasing
complexity introducing texture to our
look
level five creating texture we will be
using something called Egyptian magic
Egyptian magic is something that you can
use to add a glossy Sheen to your pieces
many industry professionals use KY Jelly
for almost everything and for this we
don't really need it to be goopy or
gooey we just want it to be very slick
and wet looking so I tend to gravitate
towards the Egyptian magic because it's
easy to apply it's shiny without being
too shiny it's not too wet it's not too
runny you can kind of control it pretty
well and it really makes things look
quite good so the way in which we're
increasing complexity is by increasing
our visual language in order to do that
we are adding different levels of
texture different pieces to really make
it come together if you wanted to make
something goopy or gooey like think
about Neo coming out of those that pod
for the first time in The Matrix that's
a substance called methyl cellulose
which is a plant-based food thickener
total consumable totally flavorless but
it is actually something that you would
buy as a powdered substance and then
boil on the stove I know because I've
done it
level six
prosthetic application
so story wise our model is now going
fully off the deep end and becoming a
full-on demon for the sake of the
schedule of our episode we've gone ahead
and acquired a pre-made demon face
Appliance in a larger production I would
prefer to craft my own demon face to
control as much of the creature's design
as I possibly can and in order to
achieve this look we are going to be
applying a full face facial prosthetic
Appliance as well as two ear appliances
one to each ear and then two sets of
horns I've asked our model to go ahead
and insert his own contact lenses prior
to our facial transformation as a safety
precaution
for this level I'm gonna have my friend
Brittany Turpin help me she is going to
assist me through the application
process and in order to make our
application as easy and seamless as
possible our first step is going to be
to prep the skin we're going to use
another round of that toner this time we
are also going to apply something known
as Skin saver it's a lotion that you put
on that acts as a barrier cream your
skin on your face is very thin much
thinner than the skin on your arms or
the skin on your legs so we want to
treat it with a little bit more TLC
removing a full facial Appliance at the
end of the day can be quite a task and
we want to make sure that he walks away
feeling as fresh as a spring chicken our
second step is going to be gluing down
our model's eyebrows which might seem
crazy but we will be using a
silicone-based adhesive known as talisis
the next part of the application will be
holding the facial Appliance up to
Andrew and seeing how it fits him we're
going to decide on exactly how we want
it to be played taste and then we're
going to take a powder puff and
powder around the edges of it so that we
know exactly where we want it to lay so
that when we go to actually glue
everything down we know exactly how it
lines up on his face
since we are using generic prosthetics
for this it is kind of impossible to say
if things will fit him perfectly until
we see it near him and it's very likely
that they won't fit like a glove it's
very common for there to be minor fit
issues especially if you don't get a
makeup test there's a variety of ways
that you can handle that sometimes we
use things called blenders they're
little patches of very thin foam latex
that you can just apply to bad saggy
crazy edges to kind of make sure that
people can't see them for this
application we're going to be using the
same silicone glue that we used to glue
down our model's brows instead of the
proze that we used for the tattoo there
is something that goes with it called
thinner which just kind of thins out the
consistency of that very thick
silicone-based glue and sometimes
instead you can use that thinner to lift
an edge that got pushed down too quickly
it adds so much more flexibility to your
application whereas with Pros Aid
once it's down it's down that's it
that's all you got good luck for our
next level we'll be increasing
complexity by painting and sealing with
Pax paint which will seal the foam and
also help us start to match our model
skin tone
level seven stippling with packs so in
this level we are going to be using
something called Pax paint which is a
mixture of prozate adhesive and acrylic
paint the reason that we're going to be
using that next is because we must seal
the foam completely before we can move
on to using any of our airbrush or
alcohol colors because foam is really
porous and it will absorb anything
that's super wet if you don't seal it
first so the acrylic and peraze mixture
creates a film a plastic film over it
that is totally skin safe acrylic paint
is very flexible so this mixture of it
and the adhesive actually flexes with
you so you'll still be able to move all
around without it cracking off like you
would think that house paint would but
it also seals it so that we can then in
our next steps use our favorite paints
to really make things come to life in
level 2 we used alcohol paint and
brushes to do stippling in this level
we're going to be using non-latex white
sponge to create a very similar
type of texture but we're using sponge
because the Pax paint can easily ruin
your brushes and those brushes are quite
expensive so we want to make sure we
take very good care of them
in order to create that texture with the
sponge what I do it ahead of time is I
will take the sponge and rip it up and
then use that to create this kind of
dimensional texture with our Pax paint
the worst mistake you can make with Pax
paint is to use way too much of it it is
a nightmare to remove there are
instances in which we'll use Pax paint
like on hands from for movies where you
know it's a totally blue guy and you
have to do what you have to do but it's
not preferential to use Pax paint
anywhere except for where you absolutely
need it level 8 spattering
while it may seem like applying the
Prosthetics is actually more difficult
than what our next step is going to be
it's something that has to be done
before we can achieve our next level I'm
going to be using one of my favorite
airbrush guns to help Elevate our look
of actual skin texture and actual skin
color so we will be really trying to
nail down that skin tone and nail down
the look of our skin we don't really
want to touch it after this level to
adjust the skin we're just going to move
on to other parts of painting after this
I like to use the spattering gun to
start things off at least there are
plenty of other spattering you can use a
chip brush that you cut off the top I
like to start with my airbrush because
it's the most uniform spray whereas when
you're doing something by hand it is
kind of dependent upon how you are
flicking it how it's feeling because I'm
also trying to nail a color I want to
make sure that my color is uniform
before I start adding in more unique
touches the reason that I am going to
use the chip brush near the eye area is
because we want to blend down those
edges but I know that I'm going to be
doing a different than flesh paint
scheme in the eye area ultimately so I'm
not quite as concerned with the
uniformity of that in the eye area and
I'm going to be using my airbrush gun
for the overall effect on the rest of
the prosthetic the types of paints that
we're going to be using for this not
just skin tone paints but we are also
going to be using Color adjusters as
well color adjusters that you might come
across even in the makeup store when you
go you know you get your corals you get
your rose adjusters you've got Olive
adjuster I'm a big fan of adjusters I
love them I feel like they are the
easiest way to make things really start
to look real you can get kind of caught
up in the minutia of using a bunch of
different skin tones but at the end of
the day once you've gotten in the realm
of your skin tone it will be really be
up to the adjusters to kind of come in
and save the day for you
if your paint is super thin you're going
to wind up doing about 7 000 passes with
your airbrush gun before you finally
start to see something happening but you
don't want your paint to be too
pigmented as well because then you're
just going to see like freckles like
everywhere just a million freckles of
everything and that gets to be very
overwhelming aim it's a push and pull of
okay for this pass I think I'm gonna do
super translucent then maybe the next
pass with a different color I'm gonna
get a little bit Bolder with it we're
gonna back off with the translucency you
really learn those things through trial
and error I try to start pretty
loosey-goosey with it and then once I
start feeling like okay we've got our
skin tone nailed down I'm gonna start
adding my freckle tone I'm gonna add my
dark Freckle tone I just like to make
sure that I give myself a little bit of
wiggle room so I'm not like committed to
a barrage of dots off the bat in our
next level we're going to be increasing
complexity by starting to really hone in
on our character we're going to be using
techniques known as modeling and
patterning to breathe a new life into
this character now that we have already
nailed down the fleshiness and the skin
tone of it and just start to really make
our character sing level 9 modeling and
patterning modeling is a term that
refers to what happens with blood in the
skin of dead bodies and it is this very
dappled kind of blood pooling that
happens it is something that we use as a
technique of paint application in
the special effects world not just when
we're simulating you know zombies or
dead bodies but also that term has come
to transcend just that application and
and start to refer to the look of
breaking up the skin in a way where the
paint kind of Ebbs and flows where you
get some areas that have this definition
and other areas that don't have it quite
as much and it's a very gorgeous
technique
patterning think of it like a snake it's
like the actual pattern of how the paint
is going to go on or how your look is
going to wind up I am going to achieve
our modeling and patterning through use
of a more precise airbrush gun this is
going to be a smaller spray pattern and
a smaller airbrush gun in general and I
am going to use modeling techniques so
people kind of refer to it as like your
crazy eighths or your your eight
patterns my favorite and it's one of the
easiest to kind of fly through but it is
really just a way of applying paint
in a non-uniform uniform way to break up
the skin and I will pattern over that
with the same airbrush gun in a very
similar manner to how we did our veining
I'm going to follow the lead of my
modeling and see how it turns out and
where it goes and then I'm going to go
in there and kind of I like to dot with
my patterning so we're going to do that
this is the level and the step in this
location where you can really let your
artist we come to the Forefront of
things in the previous levels in the
previous steps we've been just focused
on trying to create as much realism as
possible and this is where fantasy
starts to take over this is where your
ideas and and your beliefs about how you
want your character to turn out that's
where this can kind of
come to the party and
Take the Lead
level 10 dry brushing and marrying
in level 10 we're increasing our
complexity by using the techniques of
dry Brushing in particular and also the
idea of marrying all of our things
together we will be using these to just
solidify what we've done in the previous
levels and make sure that everything
comes together to create one very
uniform and very put together piece
previously to this we have ignored the
eye orbit a bit and we are going to be
using cream makeup to really bring our
paint job down into the eye orbit we're
going to use a little bit of eyeliner in
the in the eye to marry our effects
paint job and our actual like areas that
I wouldn't want to use alcohol paint for
instance I'm not going to use alcohol
pain on somebody's eyelid that's a
little mean I am going to use beauty
makeup in a non-conventionally beauty
way to bring some more life into this
and to really keep things in the realm
that I want to keep them in which is to
move away from human and to move into
fantasy and I'm going to be using a
technique known as dry brushing previous
to this we've been using wet application
techniques where the paint is very wet
as we apply it in this in particular
with the horns we're going to use a dry
brushing technique which is where you
try to get as much of the water or
whatever you use to activate with off
the brush and keep the pigment on it and
then brush that onto the horns to
enhance the texture of it and then leave
some of that paint that was already on
the horn in the areas that you want it
so really what this does is it adds
pigment to the raised parts of the piece
and leaves what you already had into the
crevices and recesses of it
level 11 final reveal for the final
level I am taking a dental impression
from my model and I am going to create a
custom set of Dentures for him so that
we can add something special to this
that is not purchasable in stores like
every other piece that we have done
previously I'll also be adding
nails to the look and a little bit more
Flair a little demon blood a little sass
there and these elements are often
overlooked but so important to helping
tell a story they really change the
entirety of the makeup they really help
sell it a little bit more and I find
them to be some of the most fascinating
parts of makeups I mean think about all
this scary things that you've seen with
like creepy teeth all over them so like
yeah we're gonna add a little creepy
teeth to this guy
[Music]
foreign
thanks so much for watching I hope you
guys learned something new about
prosthetic makeup that you didn't know
before and hopefully I've piqued your
interest enough to help you win the
Halloween costume contest this year at
your job
good luck